[Music]
[Music]
don't you think your mom would want you
to be happy
come be in the picture with that
happy
but how
[Music]
welcome
to the world of you
you may not be able to start over in the
real world
but you can start over
in the world of you
with its unique body sharing technology
you was able to draw out a user's hidden
strength
i could finally sing again
she made it unused global music charts
just as i expected i'm so sad
nobody in their right mind would ever
have that bell's user is actually a
mousy nobody like you i guess it's true
that everyone's hiding some kind of
secret
excuses something wrong
why are you still here wait who is that
a dragon this is typical internet
behavior why does he do stuff that'll
make people hate him
preserve the peace in you this creature
must be disposed of
who are you really
he's in danger what wait
i have to help him
oh girls you're singing
but i don't know what to
how are we do to find one person out of
five billion accounts
actually there's something i've been
meaning to ask you for quite a long time
now
when the truth is revealed what do you
want to bet no one will pay any
attention to a single one of your songs
[Music]
sing
[Music]
bye